switching gears now to a possible new  couple alert  yep that is jason momoa and kate  beckinsale getting cozy at the vanity  fair oscars party and fans are into it  according to e news eyewitnesses say  they both had smiles on their faces and  looked really happy at one point the  newly single star even offered his  jacket to kate to keep her warm how  chivalrous  and before they hit up jay-z's after  party an insider says he put his arm  around her a few times and she lit up  with a big smile adding they seem quote  very comfortable the photos which have  gone viral come a little more than two  months after the dune actor and his wife  lisa bonay announced their split